[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis également aux blogueuses et
rédactrice en chef les kakous ans chefs
de jeunesse quoi alors la première fois
où j'ai assisté à une conférence ted
c'était en octobre 2016 et coupé des xi
an et je me suis dit que moi aussi
j'aimerais bien un jour dire des choses
à des gens pour les inspirer
mais en ce moment là je n'avais rien à
tes mots et aujourd'hui je suis si j'ai
quelque chose à vous dire je suis venu
vous dire que moi je veux changer le
monde
généralement conçu le changement déjà
peu près la même réaction
les gens me disent tu ne te craint pas
de problème du devriez normalement
tranquillement mourir paisiblement un
jour à mener une existence comme à
cannes mais moi je pense que je peux
seulement je pense que je vais changer
le monde et je touche déjà le monde
chaque seconde la simple est la seule
personne avec le peu de ressources que
je suis change de monde chaque écoute on
peut changer les choses c'est quoi
apporter du positif passe quelque chose
qui ne va pas c'est parce que on veut le
meilleur
alors pourquoi moi je peux changer le
monde veut montrer ce qu'est le mans
pourquoi je veux changer et comment je
vais les bobos longtemps voici le mode
aujourd'hui
n'ayez pas peur pour moi l'espagne joue
donc ce qui est juste des couleurs du
lac ans alors ça c'est le rapport 2007
de latex de la fragilité des pays alors
des chercheurs ont mesuré 12 indicateurs
socio-économiques et politiques ou
aperture le les pays
tu as un tas de façons et les paysages
ce sont des pays qui ont dont les
acteurs ont des revenus bas dont les
gouvernements n'ont pas la capacité
d'entretenir l'espoir à ceux ci ont des
conditions de vie assez précaire et ces
pays là ont particulièrement plus de
chances de souffrir de guerre donc
d'avoir des configs externe et la
crainte les pays bleus sont les pays les
plus stables route de budapest ap le
canada l'australie et le pays doit
ensuite rendre payant vers les pays bas
contre les payons bleus mais ça va ils
sont stables et sûres jaune
malheureusement et sur celles à l'air
est allé voir plus l'afrique c'est le
continent avec une baisse de rouge c'est
le continent où on passe à des guerres
que n'importe quel moment
d'accord à des implosions 50 à la fin à
la mort à des maladies et puis avec des
épines et michele valley
ce n'est pas la chronique et les
épidémies et moi ce que j'appelle
changer le monde c'est de rendre la rue
et chaque fois quand je me réveille je
me dis que la wii un jour doit
maintenant comment je suis le moins de
sacs dont je vous ai dit que je change
de -2 5 jours
j'ai trois manières de changer le monde
mais valeurs bon visage aimé activement
vous savez lit ou quoi renvoyer sur ce
site oiseaux la poésie cet homme colibri
ce sont des oiseaux très petit et très
abouti il ya un an c'est ce poisson
d'avril qui a commencé à déneiger ma vie
parce que j'ai entendu la légion du
possible
comment raconte des histoires souvent
alors un jouet ya eu un grand feu de
forêt et tous les mêmes droits et le
petit lait versé est donc un animal est
agacé gatti mais c'est de la folie parce
que tu ne pourras jamais éteint le feu
avec beaucoup d'eau elle voulait couture
bonté que je ne vais pas tarder le feu
mais au moins je fais ma ma et lorsqu'il
a fait ça tous les autres exposants
sortie et chacun avec ses moyens avec
ses compétences avec ses qualités
ce ne sera pas évident et depuis que
j'ai oublié que je veux plus que j'ai
entendu cette histoire ma vie à roubaix
change parce que quand j'étais enfant je
répète changer le monde mais quand j'ai
commenté les choses soient parus
différemment je veux faire du coin de
systèmes au look est arrivé et je me
suis dit que je vais mener les distants
à une existence paisible comme tout le
monde dit i mourir paisiblement un jour
mais ce poison la barre du mot rêve
d'enfant avec notre âme et je me suis
dit à chaque fois je vais même à bas des
moments où je décide de ne pas gêner un
sachet de là où j'ai changé le move
c'est une petite action il vaut presque
rien une des mines ou non mais ma mère
mais ça a changé non plus il y a oh mais
sa vie alors et dans une étudiante en
sciences politiques sciences politiques
sciences sociales n'obligeait j'ai
l'habitude de me plaindre
quel que soit ce qu'on va dire est ce
que vous savez que c'est la bonne
direction
certains palaces et à l'économie à
l'humanité c'est la politique basque
sont les politiques décisives quelle est
l'économie a donné quelques sociale et
donc je mets des mini jeux med est 10e
quand j'observe a peur de moi y aller
parce qu'on est con et moi pour moi la
politique c'est comme les mathématiques
si vous ne savez pas faire de choix
c'est vraiment grave et c'est dommage
alors moi je me suis dit je vais pas
remettre et c'est alors qu'est ce que je
fais ja smartphones j'adore aller sur
internet
je me suis mise à nu et c'est comme ça
que je suis devenu blogueuse
alors je vous signez zazie et la bonne
image mais est-ce que de manière
tellement ça l'a cependant pas les
moyens j'attends d'abord mais cet hiver
à ce pays que ces personnes là poussent
encore connaître leurs responsabiités
connaître leurs droits parce que si vous
ne savez pas soir en droit vous ne
pouvez pas me répondit si vous ne savez
pas ce que vous devez faire vous ne
pouvez pas le but et c'est comme ça que
j'ai commencé à bloguer
je ne la ligne éditoriale
on parle de politique on parle de 6 en
barque d'action citoyenne où on parle de
guilhem social tout ce qui pourrait
déboucher la souris et comment connaît
la société dans laquelle on vit
et comment la faire à dos c'est ça qu'on
parlera 11
[Musique]
et j'ai commencé à bloguer en octobre
2010 et par un record 2016
et moi j'ai envie je sais pas quelle
rigueur au début quand j'ai commencé je
ne m'étais pas produit des livres je ne
m'étais pas dit que dans quelques mois
et des billets de pascal heymes juillet
dans la rue je mets des balisages avait
confié je voulais juste partager sa vie
et ça m'a fait plaisir de savoir que les
jeunes que j'arrivais à engager des
jeunes et que j'arrivais n'a changé
c'est une personne qui payeraient pour
me dire peu même si je veux changer le
mode moi aussi je fais chaque jour
quelque chose pour les choses meilleures
et c'est comme ça que les jeunes se sont
proposés pour m'accompagner en juillet
mais c'est israël il a été honoré avec
munich lucio un acquittement des
articles on a vu son engagés il fait
partager cette maison ce qui est
important pour nous et le partage des
voix c'est le partage d'informations sur
mon a reçu
comment me donnez vous vous avez des
personnes de tout et rend les gens qui
fait son soutien aux enseignants mais
qui arrivent chaque jour à prendre aux
autres et nous incite toujours nous
sommes une bonne vie ici vous n'allez
pas aider le processus politique
on avait à faire mais nous avec nos
petits moyens nous arrivons à si vous
voulez pas enseigner ou partager tout ce
que nous savons c'est la petite
la vice-doyenne le bien-être social issu
d'un groupe en général et on insiste
beaucoup sur perret général parce que je
me dis que j'ai dix secondes mais c'est
parce que chacun passe à convaincre
qu'on n'aille pas vous imaginer que dans
votre vie de tous les jours si vous
posez peut la petite action que vous
mettez pas impacter une famille et dans
une casserole faites la bonne part parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on va commencer
avant c'est ce que je fais est ce que ça
va la personne 500 km 2 mois ou à silly
il omettait de ne pas dans la corne de
l'afrique
est-ce que ça est-ce que ça impacte
positivement l'arrêt de cette personne
et c'est ça que vous voulez gré la bamba
moi que je répare et de mes ambitions
c'est vrai but régler mais je me suis
dit que je ne vais pas faire pas
[Musique]
donc est ce que je fais emballages
étaient allés dans la commune d'abobo
il y avait un jeune homme est jugé sur
les résultats
il m'envoie un message pour aider
peuvent tout ce que j'écris je suis
vraiment fier de son destin aux femmes
de son parti
elles ne comprennent pas bien et il ne
règle que je vienne
dans son quartier alors pour leur part
les deux suisses n'a pour l'heure pas
leur boulot pas le choix quanti et je
vais du dacquois vont tout donner
alors je suis allé moi j'aimerais vous
et certains ne sont jamais allés à
l'école anne europacorp à la norme
française est donnée comme la comprends
bien la langue il a été suivi d'une
traduisez vous et ça a été une manière
pour moi de me rapprocher des
compilations venez soir vraiment ce
qu'elles vivent ce qu'elle pense
c'est dément une expérience unique pour
moi et j'ai continué je suis repris
vous imaginez une vie va sacrifier son
embauche pour aller parler à des gens
dans un quartier qu'on dit dangereux
c'est ce à quoi la bête donné le soir à
la remontée conscience ici j'étais sous
presse
c'est le jour de l'indépendance c'est
parti avec mon équipe nous n'étions pas
partis pour pour faire comme tout le
monde nous sommes partis par les deux
stylistes rauzan parce que je pense que
nous devons assurer la relève
les improbables et du comportement
citoyen avoir des valeurs républicaines
alors nous sommes allés nous avons réuni
spontanément ce mercredi voir adapté aux
enfants ont fait ce soir en fait les
colonies colony met l'effort la carte de
la côte d'ivoire les emplettes pour
qu'ils puissent garder ou qui sont un
peu voir envers les autres et ça ce sont
les actions que nous mêmes nous avons
monté sur une petite faction bennoo à
première vue savoir 1 500 e vaut pas
grand chose et chaque fois c'est ce
qu'on appelle dans une
c'est ici la salle hermine a prévenu
jeudi que je fais une différence entre
la connaissance et l'éducation
la connaissance et les pins campagne
c'est la joie de ma fille c'est 10 boire
c c l'algérie mais l'équipe est sous ce
sont les paillotes vous permet
d'utiliser ses connaissances ses
connaissances malaisie anticons auront
besoin de personnalités sur un grand
besoin de casoni n'ont pas besoin d'une
modulation opposants n'ont pas seulement
besoin de ça parce que je ne suis pas
docteur qui a fait 7 1 me donniez il est
très étudiée mais parce qu'il n'a pas
les idées sont athlétiques et noir pense
que c'est un abus de langage
il a la connaissance mais il n'est pas
et nous parce que nous ne pouvons pas
tous bienvenue mais pas fous ils
réfléchissent pour compte revoir les
bombes à comines redéfini son délit les
jours mais pourquoi estivants on
s'envoie des arbres peuvent détruire
tout un pays est souillé les millions de
vies parce qu'il ya l'éducation et comme
je veux dire les programmes issus d'un
pays ce sont ses ressources humaines
si les ressources du melhoun développe à
des valeurs morales hausse des prix j'ai
vu faire la nation entière
mais les épines alors n'en ai jamais
voir un pays stable politiquement qui
vous inconnu avoir de succès
économiquement ou on gagne
les pays sont vraiment un taux est
exagéré de l'option d'un cérémonie alors
ce que nous essayons d'apporter chaque
jour vous c'est l'éducation
c'est pas forcément la connaissance mais
c'est comment utiliser ses connaissances
pour arriver à un certain niveau
d'intelligence émotionnelle ce que vous
faites pas là mais juste vous permet des
régions de fès vous a gardé ses mains
des gens et vous devez avoir
l'intelligence émotionnelle qui vous
emmène à penser chaque jour à l'autre or
de faire quelque chose ya pa seconde
ducati par petits bouts là où vous êtes
car tout est possible de bien une fois
sauvé transformé par porical et chez
nous on va vous dire que c'est peu mais
c'est beaucoup d'amour ont fait passer
le même qu'en chacun fera sa part selon
ses moyens
parce que tu parles je veux c'est que je
vais parler avec mes pascal faisant
passer par le menu donc je me disais du
royaume uni je n'ai pas de dommage
j'aurais eu des regrets non mais j'ai
commencé j'ai commencé à parler et les
gens ont commencé à demander et moi je
peins pas entendu personne chaque fois
j'emmène de personnes et le bas est mort
ce soir
sa part que l'afrique devait je parle de
la vie entre le monde parce que c'est la
désunion
l'afrique c'est ma fille et mon rêve
serait que par l école où ce serait
qu'on puisse mondiale au drame ce serait
peu les fameux vin ne soient que des
jeunes soient préparés de force à 12 ans
ce serait que les enfants ne meurent
plus de famille se serait compétitive
une vie décente
parce que tout être humain a droit à une
liaison
et moi je crois que je peux jouer
je crois fermement je fais ce changement
est l'amie qui m'a dit quand on prend
soin de combat faut pas penser -
s'accordent pour même maintenant à voir
les résultats des religions il faut
juste
je vois beaucoup de personnes je
travaille donc avec nous ce soir mais je
vois plein de jeux ce plan je parlais de
la fuite des cerveaux qui je disais à
les alimenter homonyme c'est vraiment
difficile on prenne paroisse du travail
a toujours été
parce que boire des décennies en
entretenu et de nous assurer que ces
personnes là possible mais on prend
beaucoup de buts et que cécile sur cinq
entre 100 ans
on va commencer et c'est ça ma peine
aujourd'hui le futur ça
alors il faut commencer maintenant il
faut pas confier je dis que c'est aussi
parce que si on retrouve ce que c'est
difficile on ne va pas commencer et moi
ça n'a pas été là je me dis que s'ouvre
la porte je fais comment
et d'autres jeunes loups et on ira
ensemble
je n'ai pas comparé forcément à voir la
route bleue de mots vivants des sports
sur la mer noire
je m'attends pas forcément avoir zéro
mais ma satisfaction
ce serait d'avoir beaucoup et la marine
et votre perso
[Applaudissements]